The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK,
let's get started.
Can we get them up?
So this is our thing spinning.
What are the units of
the generalized force
in this problem, which
is going to be related
to the torque at the bottom.
So most people
said Newton meters,
which is the units of torque.
And that would be correct.
So you're going to get
some i theta double dot
kind of equation of
motion with this,
as units of moment or torque.
And any external
non-conservative force on it
would in this case
have units of torque.
OK, next.
So we have a pendulum,
kind of an odd shape.
That is, does it
have symmetries?
Name a symmetry
that this thing has.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You mean axial
then, or a plane, or what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Axis or a plane, OK.
So this thing has symmetries.
You could convince
yourself pretty quickly
that the principal
axes with one big
break down the center of it.
And the other two would
be perpendicular to that.
So is it appropriate to use the
parallel axis theorem to find
an equation of motion of this
thing for when it's pinned
at the top?
And most people said
yes if you said no.
I think parallel
axis theorem works
just great in this problem.
It's planar motion, and the,
for example, kinetic energy
you can write as 1/2i about
o up there, the hinge point.
i with respect to that
point theta double dot.
And to do i about
that point, you'd
use the parallel axis theorem.
So i about g plus the
distance l squared times m.
This one.
Do you expect a centripetal
acceleration term
to show up in your
equations of motion?
And some said yes, some said no.
So the equation of
motion for this,
I would probably write
in terms of some rotation
theta of the big disk.
And that will cause the mass on
the string to move up and down.
But for the rotating
parts of the system,
are there-- I'll think of
a clear way to word this.
Let's ignore the little mass
going up and down for a moment.
The axis of rotation of
that double disk and hub
and the bigger disk,
does the axis of rotation
go through the center
of mass of that disk?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Is it statically balanced?
We haven't talked about
balancing in a while.
Good review question for
thinking about a quiz
next Tuesday.
So what does it
take for something
which is rotating to be
considered statically balanced?
The axis of rotation must what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: He says pass
through the center of mass.
Anybody else have a suggestion,
different suggestion?
If the axis of rotation passes
through the center of mass,
is it statically balanced?
AUDIENCE: It has to
be a principal axis?
PROFESSOR: Does it have
to be a principal axis?
What do you think?
Is that axis passing through
g have to be a principal
axis in order for it to
be statically balanced?
Let's see.
I don't have a little--
no, it's too big.
This is just a wheel.
And this is my axle going
through the center of mass.
And it goes through
the center of mass,
and it'll have no tendency
to swing down to a low point
because the weight, its
weight, is acting right
on its center of mass.
And with respect to this
axle, there's no moment arm.
So there's no torque
caused by gravity
that could cause this to put its
center of mass below the axle.
So it doesn't
matter, even if I had
the axis going through here.
As long as that axis
passes through g,
there is no tendency for this
thing to swing to a low side
because the mass mg is
acting right on the axle.
No moment arm.
So the only condition
for static balance
for a rotor of any kind,
something rotating,
to be statically balanced
is for the axis of rotation
to pass through the mass center.
So the rotating part of this
system, the axis of rotation
passes through the mass
center, that big disk.
Does the little mass, m, rotate?
So it can't be statically
or dynamically in balance.
It's not a rotating system.
It's just a little
translating mass
that happens to be
pulled up and down
by the action of this thing.
So the question
was, do you expect
a centripetal acceleration
term to show up?
The answer's no.
So let's get back to that.
If you have a static imbalance--
let's say my axis of rotation
is here.
This is definitely
statically imbalanced now.
Its mass center is down here.
The force of gravity pulls it
down until it hangs straight.
That's how you can just test
to see if you're passing
through the mass center.
So if you have an axis that
does not pass through g,
then you're
statically imbalanced.
And if you rotate
about that axis,
is there a net centripetal force
required as it goes around?
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because the center
of mass is on the outside.
PROFESSOR: So the center of
mass is some distance away.
And you're swinging
it around and around
and make that center
of mass go in a circle.
You're applying a
centripetal acceleration
to the center of
mass, and that takes
a force, which you sometimes
think of as a centrifugal force
pulling out.
That's what you're going
to have to pull in,
some m r omega squared.
So no centripetal term would
be expected in this problem.
Let's go to the next one.
This one, you had two
different conditions.
Either rolling without
slip or rolling with slip.
And the question is,
for which conditions
are the generalized
forces associated
with a virtual displacement
of delta theta,
the rotation of the
wheel, equal to zero?
So remember,
generalized forces are
the forces that account for
the non-conservative forces
in the problem.
So if it's rolling down
the hill without slip,
are there any non-conservative
forces acting on it?
Is there a friction
force acting on it?
Yeah, but does it do any work?
No, because there's no delta
r at the point of application
of the force.
There's no motion.
So for which condition
does the generalized forces
equal to zero?
Certainly for the condition
when it does not slip.
What about if it does slip?
Would you expect a
non-conservative force
to do work on it?
What force would that be?
The friction force.
So now, as the wheel turns, that
point of application where it's
sliding, you're actually getting
a little delta omega, delta
theta rather.
You move a little
distance r delta theta,
dotted with the force.
You get a certain little
bit of virtual work
done, r delta theta times f.
So the only case a is
where you get zero.
Oh, this one.
What's the generalized
force associated with f?
That's this applied force.
It's applied to the rolling
thing going down the hill.
The force is horizontal.
And you're asked what's the
generalized force associated
with f due to the virtual
displacement delta x?
And x is the motion
of the main cart.
So when you're doing
generalized forces,
you think in terms
of virtual work.
Can you imagine that that
cart's moving a little distance
delta x, the main x
in the xyo system?
It shifts a little
distance delta x.
That force, does it
move-- does the point
of application of that force
move with that delta x?
That's really what the
question comes down to.
This one.
So this is your inertial
system, and it's
going to account for the
motion of this object.
And then up here,
got your wheel.
And we have some coordinate
system attached to this object,
noting the position
of the wheel as it
goes up and down the hill.
So this coordinate's
relative to the moving cart.
This coordinate's inertial.
The question's only asking then,
what is the virtual work done
that's associated width delta x
here, some motion of the cart.
And it's going to be what we're
looking for, the Qx delta x.
And when we say, OK.
At the point of
application of the force,
there's literally F here.
And it's in the horizontal
direction, which is exactly
the same direction as capital X.
So this is equal to the force.
And in the problem it's
called-- this is just
called F. It's a vector.
And we're trying to
deduce the deflection
at the point of application.
I'm going to call it some--
it can be many forces.
I'm going to call it
F sub i so that we
think of it as one of many.
Times the displacement
delta ri due to delta x.
So this is a vector.
This is a displacement.
This is a force.
The amount of work done
as this force moves
through that
displacement is some F
dot delta r, the movement
at this point i where it's
applied, due to this motion.
So what is the delta r at
this point due to that motion?
So another concept here,
when you're doing this,
you think of these
mentally one at a time.
How many degrees of freedom
do we have in this problem?
Takes two to completely
describe the motion.
x and this one
attached to the cart.
And you think of
these one at a time.
So right now,
we're asking what's
the virtual work done by that
force due to movement of this
coordinate only, assuming
this one is frozen?
So this one is not
allowed to move.
So if this is not
allowed to move,
does the position of this change
relative to this cart as you
move the cart?
No.
That one is held fixed.
It moves with the cart.
So if you move the cart
a little distance here,
delta x in this
frame, then this wheel
moves with the
cart that distance.
So how much work gets done?
So this delta ri in this
case is equal to delta x.
And the amount of
work that gets done
is delta w at point i due to
delta x here is F dot delta x,
but F is in the
capital I direction.
This is in the
So it's just F delta x.
is the work done.
And that's Qx delta x.
So the generalized
force is just F.
All right.
What else we got?
OK, wait a minute.
Oh, this is due to the dashpot.
What is generalized
force associated
with the dashpot due to
a virtual deflection x1?
Now x1's the
coordinate, that thing
rolling up and down the hill.
So now the same thing,
the dashpot force.
Here's your cart.
Here's your dashpot.
And a free body
diagram of the cart
would show a dashpot force
here, bx dot in that direction.
And if we move the cart,
again, a little bit delta
x, how much work gets done?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This is not the
question asked up there.
Just first this.
How much virtual work gets done
by that in a deflection delta
x?
Well, it's some Fi dot delta
r due to delta x, which
is just delta x.
So this is some minus bx dot
in the I direction times delta
x in the I again.
It's just in this
case it's minus.
So this virtual work done this
time due to just the dashpot.
I don't know how to write that.
I don't have a subscript.
So this dashpot
only here, bx dot,
is bx dot minus in
the I direction--
that's the force-- dotted
with the dr that it moves.
And the dr that it
moves is just delta x.
So this would be minus
bx I dot delta x I is
your virtual work that's done.
And this is equal to Qx delta x.
But this is a part of Qx
due only to the dashpot.
And you get minus
bx dot delta x.
So now we've gotten both parts
of the total generalized force
associated with the motion
delta x is F minus bx dot.
In general, this
expression Qx delta x
is the summation over
all of the applied forces
i dot delta r at i
due to, in this case,
the motion in the x direction.
And we have two
contributions here.
They come from the
applied force F and this.
So Qx in this problem
is going to turn out
to be F minus bx dot.
Now, what about
the other-- what's
really asked in this
problem is how much--
what's the generalized force
associated with the motion
of the wheel down the hill?
This is in the x1 direction.
So now you have a little
virtual deflection delta x1.
How much virtual work
gets done by the dashpot?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: I hear zero.
So a little virtual
displacement of delta x1,
does it move the main cart?
That's really what's
going on here.
Does the main cart move because
the wheel and the main cart
change relative
position a little bit?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
I hear no here.
I mean, that's the--
the coordinate x1
is the relative motion between
the cart and the wheel.
And it's independent of the
motion of the cart with respect
to the inertial frame.
So any motion of
the little wheel
does not affect the main cart.
So there's no virtual
work done by that dashpot
because the wheel moves
up and down the hill.
And it makes sense,
physical sense, right?
The wheel can sit and roll up
and down the hill all day long.
It's not going to
move that dashpot.
Next.
This problem.
I just realized this problem's
harder than I thought it was.
It's one of those things
that you look at it,
oh, that looks straightforward.
Then I looked at
Audrey's solution
and said, oh, she did it right.
And this is a little trickier
than you might think.
So are the Axyz axes,
which rotate with the hub--
so there's a rotating
there-- definitely
principal coordinates
of that rod?
That's not a problem.
But are they
principal coordinates
for that disk out on the end?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Depends if
it's slipping or not.
PROFESSOR: Depends if it's--
AUDIENCE: Slipping or not.
PROFESSOR: Actually,
I don't think so.
Let's just talk about--
principal coordinates
need to be attached
to the body, right?
So problems like this do--
let's say we're using Lagrange,
and we want to calculate
the total kinetic-- you
need to calculate the total
kinetic energy of the system.
So how would you go about
breaking this thing down
to compute the total
kinetic energy?
Would you break it into
more than one part?
What would be the natural
things to break it into?
AUDIENCE: The disk and the rod.
PROFESSOR: The disk
and the rod, right?
So the kinetic energy
of the rod, that's
pretty straightforward.
It's 1/2i with respect to the
center, theta dot squared,
omega squared.
But the kinetic energy
of that disk out
there, you need to account for
its rotation and its movement
of its center of
mass in the circle.
So let's-- I'm winging it now,
so bear with me if I make any
mistakes.
You can help me out.
T rod would be-- and
our coordinate system
is an A at the center.
There actually isn't a--
oh yeah, there's the A.
So T of the rod,
I would argue, is
1/2M of the rod omega
squared ML squared over 3.
Because it's rotating
about one end.
So apply the parallel
axis theorem.
The kinetic energy
of the rod is 1/2M i
with respect to that
central axis, omega squared.
And so that gets you
from ML squared over 12
to ML squared over 3 because
you're swinging around one end.
But now we need T of the disk.
And to do T of the
disk, I would do it
by saying 1/2M of the disk
velocity of this center of mass
of the disk in o
dot VGo-- so that
takes care of its kinetic
energy due to motion
of its center of mass-- plus 1/2
omega dot H with respect to G.
With respect to
G, can you express
H for the disk in terms of
a mass moment of inertia
and some rotations,
rotation rates?
Is it legitimate?
Remember, I started-- a few
days ago, I started the top
and said, here's the general
expression for kinetic energy.
Full 3D, right?
And it basically
was that expression.
That works full 3D.
And then when you fix a
point about which something
is rotating, a rigid body,
then you can simplify it.
But in this case, H, you could
represent the angular momentum
around G as some I omega.
And then you have to multiply
it by-- so this inside of here
will be-- you can
represent this in here
as some I omega
dotted with omega,
and you will get
the kinetic energy
due to the rotation of the disk.
What makes this problem a
little trickier than I thought--
I wasn't thinking
really clearly--
is that omega is in-- what
frame do you express omega
in when you're
computing H in terms
of mass moments of inertia?
In order to compute I, you have
to use what coordinate system?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Body fixed.
And when you compute I
omega, what's the omega?
What unit vectors is
the omega expressed in?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
It's rotating, but
it's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But in what--
so the unit vector's
associated with what coordinate
system are the ones that you
use to define omega?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The one attached
to the body or not?
Generally in terms of the
one attached to the body.
And the disk gets-- that
means they're rotating.
It gets a little messy.
So I'm not going
to do it because I
can't do it in my head.
So this one you need to do
the kinetic energy of that.
You need to use this approach.
And you have to be
careful with those.
Food for thought at office
hours and in recitation.
All right.
I had meant to start
today-- we're well in,
and I haven't even started where
I was going to really go today.
So I have kind of a broken play.
I have to decide what to drop.
Give me a moment.
So the principal thing I
wanted to talk about today
was to dig a little deeper into
finding generalized forces.
And the way we've
been doing it is
what I would call kind
of an intuitive approach.
So let's imagine we've
got a rigid body.
And I have some forces
acting on it, F1.
And at the point of application
of each of these forces,
I can have a position
vector that goes there.
So there's R1, R2, R3.
And they're all with
respect to my o frame here,
but I'm going to not
write in all the o's.
Let's say that this is
a body in planar motion.
So it's confined to a plane.
It's a rigid body.
It's like my disk there.
So how many degrees
of freedom at most
would it have if
there's no constraints?
Three, right?
It could move in the x, in the
y, and it can rotate in the z.
So potentially three
degrees of freedom.
So it'll take, let's
say, G is maybe here.
So we need three
generalized coordinates.
And they would be, say, x, y,
and some rotation of theta.
And with them, we have
virtual displacements delta
x, delta y, and delta theta.
And we use those to
figure out the amount
of non-conservative
work that happens
when you make those little
small motions occur.
And we're trying to find--
we need to find Qx, Qy, and Q
theta, the generalized
forces associated
with these small variations,
virtual reflections in R3
coordinates.
So the jth one.
I have a bunch of
forces maybe up
to here, someone
here that's some Fj.
So the generalized
force-- I don't mean that.
These are Fi's.
The j's referred to are
generalized coordinates.
So generalized
force Qj delta qj.
This is the little bit of work
done in the virtual deflection
delta qj.
And there's work done by
all of these applied forces
in the system, possibly.
Every one, if I cause there a
little delta x of this body,
it moves over an amount delta x.
All of those points of
application of those forces
move a little bit.
And therefore, at every location
a little bit of work gets done.
So in order to account
for all of the work,
I have to do a summation
of the Fi dot delta r at i.
And now this is associated
with the virtual displacement
of generalized coordinate j.
So the total virtual work
done by a displacement
of one of these is a summation
of all the little bits of work
done at all the points
of application of forces
dotted with the
amount that the point
of application of that force
moves caused by delta qj.
So in general, that's what
the total qj would be.
Now, we've done problems like
that more or less intuitively.
We figured it out and said,
OK, if it moves this much,
then it's going to
move over that much.
And if there is an angle between
them, we take the component,
and we just figure it out.
Is there a more mathematical
way of doing this?
And so I'm going
to show you that.
So we've been doing this kind
of the intuitive approach here,
the reasoning out each of the
deflections and calculating
the result. That there's
a kinematic-- there's
an explicit kinematic
way of doing this.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What is it at the
right corner? [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK, I'm sorry.
It says-- this is a delta ri.
It has double subscripts here.
This is the displacement at the
point of application of force
i due to the
virtual displacement
of generalized coordinate j.
So that an example might be,
if that's delta x over here,
the summation is over
i, is over F1 F2 to Fi.
And the deflection
is the deflection
at the point of application
i due to-- in this case
I'm talking about delta x-- due
to the virtual displacements
delta x.
And so that's-- we'd work each
one of these out and add them
up, and we'd have the answer.
But there is a more
explicit mathematical way
of saying this.
And that is to say that Qj
delta qj is the summation over i
equals 1 to N, however
many there are,
of Fi dot the derivative of ri
with respect to qj delta qj.
What's that mean?
So let's look at one of these.
So force one, there's
a position vector R1.
If I move in the x
direction a little delta x,
this point moves over
delta x in that direction,
in the x direction horizontally.
Our position vector R1 has
potentially components in the y
as well as components in the x.
But I'm only changing
it in the x direction.
So that portion of
the possible movement
of R1 due to changes in just
one of the coordinates--
in this case, I was doing
qx-- the derivative of R1
with respect to
qx, so only a part
of its total possible
movement is due to x.
This gives us that portion.
Times delta qx is
the total movement
in the direction of qx
dotted with the force.
You get the work done.
So I find this-- if I were
you, this is highly abstract.
I think we need-- let's
do an example of this
and see how it works out.
And since we were talking
about that problem,
I'll do this cart
by this method.
So I need a position
vector to the point
of application of this external
non-conservative force.
Because I'm calling
this force one,
I'll call that
position vector R1.
And it goes from here to there.
But we know that the
total motion of this point
is made up of the
motion of the main cart
plus the motion of the wheel
relative to the main cart.
And so we fall back
on our notation.
So I'll say this is R1 and zero.
Here's my point A.
It's R is the vector.
This is R of A with
respect to o plus--
and we'll better
give this a name.
What have I-- so this
is my point one here.
So this is plus R1
with respect to A.
So we've done that lots
of times, this term.
That's just how-- that point
is the sum of this vector
plus this vector.
So you have an R-- this is R1
with respect to A from here
to here.
And the sum of those
two is this one.
So this is R1 here.
OK, so let's see if we can come
up with an expression for that.
Well, this point A is just x
in the I plus some Y in the J.
That's this term.
Then I need this one.
So I want-- because I'm going
to take some derivatives
and things, I want to
get everything in terms
of unit vectors and one system.
So I know this
one, this is my x1,
and it will have a unit
vector i, lowercase i,
in this direction.
So the unit vector i here has
components in the capital IJ
system.
And this is theta,
and that's theta.
So this has-- i has
a component here,
which is cosine theta cap
I, and then this piece is
minus sine theta J.
So this should be x1,
the distance this thing
moves, broken into two pieces,
cos theta I minus sine
theta J. So that's now--
the position of this thing is
the position of the cart at A
plus the vector that
goes from A to point one,
which is the
distance x1 to here,
broken into two pieces,
an I piece and a J piece.
So now we're almost done.
So I would like to find Qx.
And Qx then should be the
summation-- well, let's see.
So I'm only going to compute the
part of the generalized force
in the Qx direction due
to just this one force.
Now, remember we
have other forces,
non-conservative
forces, acting on this.
We've got a bx dot too.
But I'm just going to do
the contribution to Qx
that comes from this force F1.
And so Qx delta x is
the virtual work done,
is F1I dot partial of R1
with respect to x delta x.
But the derivative of R1
with respect to capital
X, there's no capital
X's over here.
So nothing comes from that.
There's one right here.
So the derivative of x with
respect to x gives me 1.
I just get 1 times I back here.
F1 I hat dot I hat delta x.
So it's just F1 delta x,
which we knew intuitively
when we worked this
problem earlier, when
we were talking about it.
The amount of virtual
work that gets
done by this particular force
in a deflection, virtual
displacement delta x,
it's just F1 delta x.
But we've proven
it-- we've done it
in a very precise,
kinematic way where
we found the position vector,
worked the whole thing out.
So that's the simple one.
Let's now find the harder
one, but not much now.
So we'd like to find Qx1 due
to just this F1 only delta x1.
Well, that should be
F1I dot partial of R1
with respect to x1 delta x1.
So the derivative of R1 with
respect to x1-- this stuff
has nothing to do with x1.
The x1 only appears over here.
And the derivative of this
expression, just cosine I minus
sine theta J.
So I dot I is the only
part you get back.
This is-- and I need a delta x1.
F1I dot I is cosine
theta delta x1.
So Qx1 and F1 only here
equals F1 cosine theta.
So this time the motion
delta x1, only part of it
is in the direction of F1.
And that portion, by taking
this derivative here,
we get the contribution to
this that comes from x1.
And then dotted with
the force, we only
take that component
of that motion
in the direction of the force.
And that gives us our
total virtual work.
So here is then the
total virtual work
done by F1 due to the
little motion delta x1.
So now we've got the
contribution here
to the generalized force that
is associated with deflections
of coordinate x1.
Is that the total
generalized force
associated with generalized
coordinate x1 in this problem?
Are there Any other
non-conservative forces
in the problem that move
when delta x1 is moved?
AUDIENCE: What about friction?
PROFESSOR: Well, let's see.
Friction.
Friction, you're
presuming, on the wheel?
OK.
So he asked about
friction on the wheel.
Well, let's say that there's
no slip in this case.
Then does the friction
at the point of contact
with the wheel do any work?
No.
So do we have to account for
it as a generalized force?
No.
So how about the dashpot?
So a little virtual
deflection, delta x1,
does it make the big cart move?
No.
So are there any other
forces in the problem
that move when you cause
a small movement in x1?
No.
So in this case, this
is the total Qx1.
Up here, we found Qx,
the generalized force
due to the motion of a cart,
the contribution by F1.
But is there another
contribution?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: And it is?
AUDIENCE: The dashpot.
PROFESSOR: The dashpot.
So we get additionally
the total Qx
here total would
be the summation
of two pieces, an F1 and an
F2, which I'd call minus bx.
It's in the same
direction as delta x.
So you're going to get a
minus bx dot plus F1 would
be the total generalized force
in the capital X direction,
the movement of the main cart.
So any time you can actually
specify a position vector
to the point of application of
an external non-conservative
force, then you can
just plug it into this.
You do it at each
force that's applied.
You take the
derivative with respect
to that to coordinate
qj, delta qj.
That is the virtual work
done by each of these forces.
And you add up to get the
total virtual work done
due to a deflection at that
particular coordinate, j.
So in the case of capital of
Qx, we had two contributions
because we had two forces on the
main cart, F1 and minus bx dot.
And so the summation
in that problem,
when this is capital
X, delta X, you
have two contributions,
F1 and F2.
Now, what else can I do
in the length of time?
Actually, let me stop for a
moment there, think about this.
Would you have any
questions about this?
So we've described two ways
of getting generalized forces.
One's kind of the
intuitive one, figure out
how much it moves
in the direction
and do the dot product.
The other one is straight
mathematical way.
Kinematics.
Plug it in, take the derivative,
same thing will come out.
So while you're thinking
about a question,
I'll look and think what
I was going to do next.
I know what I'll do next, but do
you have any questions on this?
I'm going to do another
example of this.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
PROFESSOR: Ah, Christina, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I still
don't understand how
if you're going to grab
the wheel and move it,
how that doesn't move the disk.
Because they're attached,
so I don't get it.
PROFESSOR: Is the wheel--
it's all in how you specify
your generalized coordinates.
So in this problem, the
two generalized coordinates
are this capital X in
the inertial system which
describes the
motion of the cart,
and little x1
describes the motion
of the wheel
relative to the cart.
And actually that allows
you to write this statement.
This is only
relative to the cart.
So the motion of the cart
plus the motion of the point
relative to the cart gives
you the total motion.
And you've picked
two coordinates
that allow you to
describe those two things.
So if you can-- in this
problem, if this is the cart,
this is the wheel, I even have
a spring hooked to it here,
if I move this a little bit,
the cart doesn't have to move.
This going back and forth
accounts for x1 relative
to this table.
And the table's the cart.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You mean dynamically
because you're putting forces
on it?
Yeah, well it might.
But that's not-- in a way,
you're asking the question,
is the cart capable
of moving because you
put a force in the wheel?
You move the wheel, which puts
more spring force, which maybe
that causes the cart to move.
Yeah, that could happen.
But that's not
the problem you're
solving when you're trying to
find the generalized forces.
You're, in fact, allowing
a single motion at a time.
So if you're talking
about this motion,
you have frozen the
motion of the main cart.
And you figure out what
the consequence of that is.
It does a little virtual
work because there's a force.
And you get one of the
generalized forces.
Then if you move the
cart, you fix the wheel,
and the whole cart moves.
But the amount that
this wheel moves
is exactly equal to the
amount that the cart
moves because you've now
fixed this relative position.
And that's where you get
the first-- that's where
you get the capital Qx term.
Even know this force F1 is
applied here on the wheel,
this wheel moves
when the table moves.
But the table doesn't move
when this relative coordinate
between the table
and here changes.
It doesn't have to.
This is free to move
when the table is frozen.
Remember we talked about
complete and independent
coordinates?
x1 is independent of
capital X. If I freeze x1,
and I make capital X
change, just the whole thing
moves like that.
If I freeze capital
X, x1 can still move.
So you have to pick
independent coordinates.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
mass of the whole thing
is much larger than
the mass of the wheel?
PROFESSOR: Not at all.
AUDIENCE: Because [INAUDIBLE]
if you have two massed connected
by a spring, you
pull the first one,
they kind of pull
each other along.
So why don't you get the
pull-along effect over here?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
It's similar-- it's
essentially the same question
that Christina asked.
He asked basically--
let's think about it.
Let's do a problem like that.
Let's have two carts and
a spring in between them,
and they're both on wheels.
This is a planar motion problem.
Each of these bodies is
capable in planar motion can
have x and y and a rotation.
But because of constraints,
how many degrees of freedom
does body one have?
I hear one, right?
I don't allow it to rotate.
It's got two wheels.
I don't allow it to go up
because it's on the ground.
I only allow it to
move in this direction.
Same thing to be said for this.
Only one there.
How many degrees of freedom
do I have in this problem?
One for each mass, right?
So I have two
degrees of freedom.
How many generalized
coordinates do I need?
So my generalized coordinate
for this one will be x1,
and for this one
will be some x2.
If you're going to do this
problem by Lagrange, and let's
see.
Let's put a force now to
get back to your question.
Let's put a force here on one.
And we'll call it F1.
And the potential
energy-- actually, no, I
don't want to do that.
So the potential energy
for this is some 1/2k times
the amount that you
stretch the springs, right?
So you're going to-- the
difference between x1 and x2
minus the unstretched length.
So x1 minus x2 minus
the unstretched length.
We'll call it l0.
So this would be the
stretch of the springs.
If the spring had
no length, then it
would just be the difference
in these two positions squared.
So my potential energy
looks something like that.
Now we want to
compute the general--
and you could use
Lagrange, and you
could figure out two
equations of motion
for this taking
your derivatives.
But the point of
the question was
about getting to the
generalized forces, right?
So now the generalized
force Qx1 delta x1
is F1 times the derivative of
R1 with respect to x1 delta x1.
So how much does
the position vector
from marking the position of
this cart, which would be R1--
so R1 is in effect x1, right?
It's a pretty trivial problem.
So the derivative of R1 with
respect to x1 is just 1,
and the amount that it
then moves is delta x1.
So the virtual work done by
this force on that first cart
is just Qx1 equals F1.
That's the generalized
force caused
by this first mass on the cart.
What's the generalize force Qx2?
Well, it's some F1.
Actually, there's a dot here.
This would be some x2 with
respect to x1 delta x1.
But how much does
x2 move when you
cause a little
virtual deflection
of-- the virtual
work done if I cause
a little deflection
of this one is
equal to the summation
of the forces that
act through delta x2.
Now, if you move this
a little delta x1 here,
we figured out that that
Qx1, the generalized force
due to that, is indeed this.
But what's the generalized
force associated
with motion delta x2?
Let's move this one
now a little bit.
When you move that a little
bit, how much work does F1 do?
So we need to get two
equations of motion, right?
And you're going to get
1 by taking derivatives
with respect to coordinate x1.
You're going to get an
equation of motion, which--
so EOM x1 associated
with x1 double dot
here is going to have on the
right hand side some Qx1.
And we figured out what that is.
It's just F1.
And we're going to get a second
equation of motion associated
with x2 double dot,
the mass acceleration
of the mass of the second one.
And it's going to be equal
to some external forces.
And there's other
terms in here, right?
We have kx.
You have your k terms
and so forth in here.
But on the right hand side are
the external non-conservative
forces.
So are there any
non-conservative forces
on the second mass?
None.
So what do you expect Qx2 to be?
So to get back to your
point, when you're
computing the
generalized forces,
you freeze all of the
movements except one
and figure out the work done.
Even though in the
real system, force
will result in
this whole system--
that whole system will
move to the right.
If I put a steady
force F1 on there,
the whole system will go
off to the right hand side.
That would be the solution
to the equations of motion
that you end up with.
But for the purpose of
computing the generalized force
on each mass, you only
fix where the masses
are at some instant in time.
And then one
coordinate at a time
cause a little
virtual deflection
and figure out how
much work gets done.
So see the distinction
between the solution
to the full equation to motion?
Yes, indeed.
Everything's going to move
because of that force.
And a little bit
of work that gets
done due to the motion of
just one coordinate and then
the other coordinate through all
of the non-conservative forces
that are applied.
Did that get to your question?
All right.
Now, I'll set up-- I don't think
I'll have time to finish this.
So last time we had this
problem, this is this rod.
It's got a sleeve,
and it's got a spring.
And we figured out the potential
and kinetic energy equation
to motion.
This is a planar motion problem.
It pivots.
Thing can slide up and down.
Requires an angle
theta and a deflection
x with respect to the rod.
And we figured out t
and v, and we found
the equations of motion for it.
So here's my system.
Point A here, spring,
sleeve, theta, x1, y1.
And the distance x1 was
measured from here to G,
to the center of mass.
That's x1.
This is in the direction here.
This is the i1 unit
vector direction.
And the coordinate
system is my x1, y1.
So x1, it's down
the axis like that.
And this problem is a
planar motion problem.
There's two rigid bodies,
the rod and the sleeve.
And we can completely describe
the motion of the system
with it has two
degrees of freedom.
Theta defines the
position of the rod,
and x1 defines the position
of the sleeve on the rod.
So we have two
degrees of freedom.
And when we work
this out, we end up
with two equations of motion.
And this was called M2.
This was M1.
So one equation of
motion was M2 x1 double
dot That was one
equation of motion.
And I'm just leaving
the generalized force
out of this for a minute.
We'll figure it out.
And the second
equation of motion.
This is the rod.
So you get two
equations of motion.
We worked it out in
the last lecture.
And we can see this
accounts for the mass moment
inertia of the rod,
mass moment of inertia
of the sleeve with respect to
G. So parallel axis theorem
adds another piece to it.
The whole thing,
theta double dot.
And then this is
just due to gravity,
gravity acting on the rod,
gravity acting on the sleeve.
And on the right
hand side, you need
to get these Qx, your
generalized forces
for generalized coordinate
x1 and generalized
coordinate theta.
So we did it, in fact
worked it out last time
doing the intuitive approach.
And what if we were
to try to do this then
by the kinematic approach
that I described here?
The force was applied here.
It was horizontal.
We called it F2 because it
was applied to mass two.
And in order to
use this technique,
we want now to compute Qx1.
We have a force F2, and
it is in the-- which
way do I want to do it?
We'll have an inertial system.
So we need to describe a
vector in-- I better not
draw it out here.
So I'll just set
this problem up,
and we'll finish it next time.
I have an inertial
system y and x.
So that in this
system, this force
would be F2 capital J
dotted with the derivative
of some vector that
runs here to this point.
And I'll call that R2 in o.
So the derivative of R2
with respect to x1 delta x1.
And if you can work this
out, then you're done.
The key to this is
figuring out what is R2,
and doing it in
unit vectors such
that you can complete
this dot product.
So how would you describe
what is this position to here,
and what are its unit
vectors that break it down?
Take this R2, and you
express it in terms
of unit vectors in the inertial
capital I capital J system.
And once you've done that,
you can take the derivative,
dot it with that,
and you're done.
So we'll finish that next time.
You might go off and think
about it in your notes
from last time.
We already figured this out.
We just did it
the intuitive way.
Drew the F and figured out
which part's in the direction
of x1, which part's in the
direction of delta theta.
And we figured it out.
So you actually already
have the answer.
So go see if you can do that.